You know, sometimes I look at the scammers these days and I wonder,
could we do better than this? I mean,
is this the best the scammers have to offer right here?
Six K K Andrew on Tik TOK, you know,
waving 30 K around as if anyone's going to believe that he actually makes that,
is this really what we have is this the best 2020 can muster?
One year ago I dropped out of high school and to pursue is spelled it e-commerce
and I think he needs to go back to high school. Oh,
people said it was a bad decision,
but I ended up making a hundred K in my first year. Okay.
Will you think a hundred profit? No, a hundred K in sales,
which means probably like 15 K in profit. So he's like,
you guys think I'm an idiot for dropping out of high school,
but I made 15 K last year. Uh, yeah, we think you're dumb.
But my point is, this is the kind of stuff that it gets sent all the time.
And I want to tell you, there was an age of scammer where people had class.
I feel like it's like when the joker says, you know,
we need a better class of criminal. This.
Deserves a better class.
Hey, you guys are doing enough.
It's hard to even want to respond to this stuff. Honestly,
I don't even know how to get out of bed in the morning when I look at this
stuff. But let me tell you in the nineties, things were done very differently.
Just compare and contrast this with this ladies and gentlemen,
how to get a second paycheck, Hawaiian style. This is from the nineties,
but it hits different. Trust me, watch and learn.
Hawaii. One of the most beautiful places on earth.
Wow. The production value. The hired actresses in the back,
walking conveniently right next to this guy.
My name is Michael Flynn and I'm here on the beautiful Island of Mali.
I've got a question for you right now. How would you like to be in Hawaii?
I would, Michael. I would like that very much.
Enjoying the good life and earning even more money than you do right now at
home. When you're slaving away at your regular job.
Michael, you've got my interest. Okay.
Because I am slaving away here making YouTube videos.
The people at home don't know, this is the hardest job in the world. Very tough.
So I'm ready, Michael. My body's ready for whatever you have for me.
You've went to Hawaii for me. So I owe it to you to watch this.
In effect. I wouldn't. You like to get a second paycheck, Hawaiian style.
It doesn't sound too bad. Oops. Already B roll on point.
Look guys remember, remember what you could be having.
You could be having this guy or you have this.
I think the answer's clear.
Just imagine Hawaii. The land of enchantment and magic.
The waterfalls, the land of volcano,
the volcanoes luaus, and of hula dancers, tropical rain forest,
and the most beautiful beaches in the world.
This is another reason the nineties infomercials just hit different.
You had Tom VU with his babes back in the day, calling them waterfalls,
watching waterfall and the front.
The waterfall of the back,
the fall look like the leg waterfall inside the house.
Now we got the beaches and the most beautiful beaches in the world.
Guys, the nineties infomercials next level. Okay.
They knew how to play. You subtly your psychology, right?
Hawaii, where you can be skin diving in the morning,
parasailing after lunch,
shopping in mid-afternoon sipping a Mai Tai at sunset.
And yet all the while you were making more money than you ever dreamed of.
See, look, we already know it's a scam, right?
But I'm there mentally. I'm in Hawaii. I've got the beaches.
I've got the tropical rainforests. I've got it all.
Even though I know it's a scam. That's what made the nineties different.
If you think that's impossible,
you're in for a surprise because in the next 30 minutes,
you're going to meet a man who does all of that. Okay.
Let's get forward and meet the man. All right. This is the real man of the hour.
That's right. He has an intro, man. The Michael, he doesn't really matter.
This is the guy that matters. This is Gary Cochran.
Than you ever dreamed possible.
And you can do it with a very simple business called direct marketing,
$200 billion a year industry. That's a figure most of us can't comprehend.
Can you even imagine what? $200 billion looks like George,
go ahead and bring him in.
Are they bringing in $200 billion?
What's the wheel barrel about what are these men doing?
They seated in your seat. These guys do not have a great sense of humor. Now.
Hey, Mr. Beast, calm down.
This is what I'm talking about. Listen,
you can either have tiny Tim over here or you can have the Cochrane.
Okay? Look at this guy. Whoo.
That's a wheelbarrow full of cash. Actually. It's not one. It's not two, three.
Over 92 million of the four ordered by either mail or
phone six wheelbarrows of cash. That's how much I have right here on the stage.
$380,000.
That's what's earned in direct marketing every minute. Now,
who would like some of this cash? If I guarantee you some,
what would you do with it? What would you do with.
He's doing a genius move right now.
I'm going to tell you what it is in a second, but watch what he does.
So first he primes people with the $20. I'll give you $20.
What would you do with it?
You'd go out to dinner. Here's $20. Enjoy yourself,
but there's not enough to take two. What would you do with it?
You have a need for a medical bill.
He's pulling the Allen before it was cool.
He gives it out to a bunch of people and then he takes it up and down.
Right? Yes. Right there. You'd go surfing $20. We'll rent you something.
All right. Now I'm not done. I still have right here.
I have some hundred dollar bills who no, no, no.
This is where the great pitch starts. Guys. He upset a hundred dollars.
Now you're prime to think. He's going to give you a hundred dollars. Watch this.
Oh wait, just a second.
I've got 100, 218, 1924, 25,
$100 bills. Who wants one of these? Guess what?
Before I'm done today, I'm going to give 25 of you. One of these $100 bills.
Watch this guys. This is genius. This is innovation. Okay.
What?
And if you're watching at home,
I'm going to give you exactly the same opportunity.
The sleazebag scammer,
a hundred percent kind of brilliant. What he's about to do.
When you get that payment,
you are going to keep your portion of the payment and you will keep it.
You will send the balance of the payment onto the producer of the product who
will ship that product directly to the consumer.
Do you understand what drop shipping is?
This is drop shipping. Oh, I finally understand this.
Guy's doing drop shipping scamming before it was cool.
Right now everybody has a dropshipping course. This guy, Hey,
back in the nineties, the innovation.
Now you're asking yourself what about the $100 Steven? What happened?
What happened to the $2,500 he was going to give away? Well, let's find out,
cause this is, this is next level.
I still have right here, 25, $100 bills.
Who wants one of these? But let me ask you if I, people literally.
Sat through this whole presentation to get this money, gave.
You one who would use it to invest in themselves and get this course of
materials and get started today. Could I see your hands?
That's exactly what I'm going to do.
You come with me and I will pay the first hundred dollars of the cost of your
program. Wait.
The minute you're not giving the buddy,
you said you're giving people money, but only if they pay you for your course,
which is 250 bucks. So, so you're just doing a sale.
But think about that. He had him wait,
the entire time everyone's paying attention.
They think there's going to be a quiz at the end.
They think they're going to get a hundred free bucks. No,
you have to pay 250 bucks to get a hundred bucks.
So that your entire cost is only $149.
Brian that's for this one right here. That's for this one right here.
And for those of you at home,
you do not have an opportunity to be at the seminar,
but I will do exactly the same thing for you.
I will pay the first a hundred dollars of the cost of this program.
You know, guys, I literally never fall for this stuff, but a hundred dollars.
Please stay on the line to continue. I.
Honestly thought that number would be disconnected for sure.
Your call is important to us. Please hold for the next available specialist.
By the way, while we're waiting.
This is one of the things I saw in the comment section of this video.
Hilariously four months ago in a video with 1900 people, I'm one of the 1900.
Due to overwhelming response.
All of our representatives are assisting other callers.
Please continue to hold for the next available representative.
Let me respond to people who are still watching Gary Cochran. Oh yeah.
It's a big, big slam. A jam ahead, boys. You know the nineties infomercials,
they're still crushing sales calls. Okay. I'm.
Gary. Now.
Due to overwhelming response,
all of our representatives are assisting other callers.
Please continue to hold for the next available representative.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry, Gary. I tried, but interesting enough, the seminar,
which is still apparently selling tons of copies. Didn't last very long.
In 1991,
they got accused of operating a scam for selling their instructive video tapes
because they didn't actually ship out the products.
See Gary Cochran owned this company called American business seminars and they
raised $400,000 by accepting money for these tapes.
But they failed to deliver the tapes and they didn't provide refunds.
So then what does Gary do?
Gary's at a pinch while he decides to file for bankruptcy.
Now the funny thing is I tried to look up more about Gary Cochran.
There isn't much available,
but I did find you guys cause I want to close the story up.
I wanted to find you the truth about this nineties,
infomercial pioneer. I wanted to know what happened to him, right?
So I found an old newspaper clipping.
This is literally from 1991.
And basically they repeat the fact that he's filing chapter 11 bankruptcy.
So he looks like his company was failing at the same time in an affidavit filed
October 25th. And this, this paper came out on November 2nd.
It says that Cochran was receiving a salary of $700,000 per month.
While his wife made a hundred thousand dollars a month classic pay gap,
ladies and gentlemen, but it looks like the end of Gary Cochran. Wasn't pretty,
I don't know, honestly, you can't find much online about him,
but I thought this is an interesting look at the scammers of old.
We think of this as a new thing on the internet, but the truth is scams.
Like this are as old as time, right? They were done in the nineties.
They were done. Even before that with chain letters, guys, this is nothing new,
but you got to educate yourself. You got to see through this stuff. But frankly,
I really do think it's easier than ever because people like this, uh,
it's disappointing. They don't have the class.
They don't have the production value of the stuff back in the day. And um,
honestly I think it's an opportunity for people now because I think it's easier
than ever to see through these guys because they don't have the showmanship,
the presentation skills back in the day. Because like, look, dude,
you look at the stuff back in the day. You almost want to buy it.
You almost want to go get a wheelbarrow of cash yourself.
But nowadays you have people like this and it's like, Oh yeah,
I know this guy's scamming me. Of course. Anyway, it's guys,
that's the video. I hope you enjoyed a look back.
And if you like content like this,
let me know and we'll keep making them all right. Thanks for watching.
Don't forget to smash like and subscribe. Thank you.
[inaudible].